[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro de 7,8 culture et tout de suite
le sommaire épidémie de kobe 19 oblige
saint quentin en yvelines a dû suspendre
activités et rendez vous des sites sont
encore fermés mais des initiatives sont
mises en place
nous ferons le point avec un responsable
d'at reporter résidence annuler toutes
les salles saint-quentinoise ont dû
baisser le rideau
même si elles sont aujourd'hui dans
l'attentes danos de l'état elle pense
déjà à la reprise et plusieurs sites ont
pu réouvrir petit musée château
nous ferons le point sur plusieurs idées
sorties culturelles et loisirs les
équipes de l'agglomération sont sur le
pont pour favoriser son ouverture le
musée de la ville pourrait accueillir à
nouveau du public dans le courant du
mois de juin
l'exposition sur les sièges dans les
années 60-70 sera toujours à découvrir
[Musique]
coup d'arrêt du côté de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines médiathèque
fermée saison culturelle terminée
bonsoir geoffroy grève vous êtes le
directeur général adjoint la proximité à
l'agglomération
la décision a notamment été prise de ne
pas ouvrir les médiathèques pour
l'instant bonsoir oui effectivement
cette décision que l'on peut qualifier
de sages a été prise il y a quelques
jours de ne pas ouvrir les médiathèques
au grand public dans la mesure où
effectivement nous ne sommes pas
forcément en capacité de pouvoir
aujourd'hui et dans l'immédiat recevoir
l'ensemble des publics
donc on a préféré pouvoir s'organiser
mais fermeture des médiathèques au
public jusqu'au 1er septembre ne veut
pas dire fin de l'activité au contraire
les équipes sont mobilisées pour pouvoir
justement proposer des activités
culturelles qui pourrait être en ligne
est également la possibilité d'organiser
un drive permettant tout de même aux
saint quentinois de pouvoir reprendre
une activité de réservation et de prêt
de livres
j'imagine que tout se passe en numérique
les ados n'ont été prolongée et il ya
même des ressources numériques qui on
est et qui sont toujours disponibles en
fait oui effectivement au début de la
période de confinement ça a été une
grande demande et les équipe et moi même
avons effectivement décidé de pouvoir
ouvrir la totalité des ressources
numériques en libre accès pas simplement
pour les saint quentinois qui était déjà
préalablement inscrits dans les
médiathèques
on a souhaité effectivement donner cette
possibilité à tous les saint quentinois
d'y accéder de manière très libre
nous avons aussi effectivement augmenté
considérablement nos budgets notamment
en termes d'achats de ebooks pour
pouvoir permettre aux saint quentinois
d'avoir une variété de livres en
c'est direct et nous avons augmenté la
presse puisque nous sommes passés de 5
accès simultanés presse à san accès
permettant là aussi de pouvoir être sûr
de la presse nationale internationale
quotidienne hebdomadaire mensuelle est
ce que vous avez senti les saint
quentinois justement aller vers ces
ressources numériques un besoin
d'évasion d'information oui oui oui
effectivement il faut quand même dire
qu'on pratiquement 230 personnes
nouvelles ont bénéficié de cette
ouverture aux ressources numériques
c'est une c'est un nombre qui est plutôt
encourageant
ça aurait pu être plus important mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nos ressources
numériques sont déjà très bien
identifiés le portail de la médiathèque
fonctionne bien et les saint-quentinois
ont pris l'habitude déjà depuis de
nombreux mois de pouvoir accéder à ces
ressources numériques est effectivement
beaucoup de demandes se sont portées sur
la presse les ebooks ont été également
un grand succès avec certains titres
sans doute en lien aussi avec l'épidémie
de kovy d' on était plus emprunter que
d'autres alors bien sûr cette épidémie
n'a pas touché que les médiathèques ça
concerne tous les sites culturels la
commande et qui voit notamment
l'annulation du village des futurs
zinsou est est aussi le musée de la
ville puis effectivement la commanderie
et et musées sont deux lieux culturels
là aussi identifié par les saint
quentinois
nous étions et nous sommes toujours sur
la deuxième année de fonctionnement de
la commanderie et c'était effectivement
un véritable crève coeur que nous avons
suivirent puisque effectivement nous
avons décidé d'annuler l'ensemble des
propositions et ce jusqu'à fin juin
nous avons aussi annulé tous les
ateliers avec les établissements
scolaires notamment les rencontres de
danse à l'école qui sont toujours très
prisés nous avons tout de même réussi à
mettre en place
là aussi par le biais d'outils
collaboratifs en lien avec l'éducation
nationale des actions permettant aux
parents
aux enseignants et aux élèves de pouvoir
revoir aussi certaines actions qui
avaient eu lieu précédemment
vous parlez de fin juin on sait qu'en
juillet notamment la commanderie ça
bouge aussi à partir en livres le cinéma
en plein air est-ce que c'est toujours
dans les cartons ou vous laisser du
temps et vous attend des nouvelles
annonces gouvernementales
alors c'est toujours dans les cartons
bien entendu à la condition
effectivement que les prochaines
annonces gouvernementales attendues pour
début juin nous donne effectivement
cette possibilité de pouvoir les
organiser en toute sérénité et en toute
sécurité
je n'ai pas voulu prendre la décision de
suite d'annuler ces événements je crois
qu'il faut qu'on ait une pensée toute
particulière pour les saint quentinois
qui n'auront peut-être pas la
possibilité cette année de pouvoir
partir en vacance de pouvoir se déplacer
et je crois qu'il est important pour une
collectivité de continuer également à
proposer une offre culturelle une offre
de loisirs durant cette période donc le
cinéma plein air pour le moment est
maintenu nous travaillons ardemment sur
une programmation et nous veillerons
effectivement de pouvoir l'organiser si
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
mais aussi si les conditions je dirais
de mise en oeuvre technique ne sont pas
trop lourde
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir aussi des
rendez-vous alternatif par les réseaux
sociaux tout à fait or les réseaux
sociaux ont bien fonctionné ont bien
chauffé jusqu'à présent je crois que les
gens aussi ont besoin de se retrouver
ont besoin de pouvoir à nouveau partager
un moment ensemble et pas forcément que
devant l'écran merci un geoffroy greffe
je le rappelle êtes le directeur général
adjoint est la proximité à
l'agglomération
et pour vous tenir au courant de
l'évolution de l'actualité culturelle
n'hésitez surtout pas à vous rendre sur
les différents sites de l'agglomération
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
les salles de spectacles restent fermées
mais certaines structures culturelles
ont pu rouvrir c'est le cas des petits
musées c'est à dire l'élu à rayonnement
local à poissy le musée du jouet a saisi
l'opportunité avec bien sûr des règles
très précises à respecter
[Musique]
l'accueil est individualisé au musée du
jouet de poissy pas question de se
retrouver dans une file épidémie oblige
l'accès est réglementé
les visiteurs doivent réserver au
préalable et venir masquer il ya des
choses plus particulière à l'intérieur
des salles qu'on a dû aménager puisque
quand le musée a réouvert l'année
dernière après des longs travaux on a
beaucoup développé tout ce qui était
tactile
là c'est tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
donc on a enlevé les espaces vieux
malheureusement donc ce serait une dit
un petit peu moins ludique mais on se
concentrera plus sur les collections une
famille par pièce des infections à
chaque passage considéré comme petit
musée le site pisciacais a rouvert ses
portes mercredi 13 mai une opportunité
saisie par cette famille yvelinoise
après deux mois de confinement
cette sortie était attendue j'aime bien
les jouer et j'aime tout seul son qui
quartier c'est une première sortie pour
nous depuis donc le confinement
même si on a tendu quand même deux trois
jours
ça nous a permis de souffler un peu puis
c'est mercredi du coup les enfants enfin
les filles n'ont pas de voir ça nous a
permis un petit peu de souffle et de
voir un petit peu autre chose
les capacités d'accueil ont été réduits
de moitié les équipes ont dû annuler les
médiations culturelles au moins jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin le musée du jouet
reçoit 18 mille visiteurs par an
bonjour lionel masse et à vous êtes le
directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la scène
nationale est impacté comme toutes les
salles culturelles de france le 12 mars
dernier les premières mesures
gouvernementales limiter les
rassemblements et à cette date là le
cadre s'apprêtait à lancer ses
quatrièmes rencontres in cité j'imagine
que ça a été un premier coup dur ben
c'est toujours un coup de vieux quand on
travaille soit les rencontres in situ
soit le reste de la programmation
puisqu'on travaille en général un an
deux ans l'avant c'est vrai que les
rangs complicité s'est créée aux un tout
petit peu particulier parce que c'est
aussi tout un travail avec des
scientifiques des partenaires donc c'est
toujours hors à l'encan ça n'engage pas
que nous mais n'en semble d'une
l'ensemble d'une chaîne de production
d'un événement bon après les rencontres
in cité c'est une chose il y avait un
certain nombre de débats de table ronde
qui était prévu je pense qu'on va
trouver un moyen de les diffuser de
l'esr d'une part et de l'édifice d'une
d'une façon ou d'une autre
voilà la situation je pensais plus est
plus compliquée pour les équipes
artistiques
maintenant tout est agitée depuis en
deux mois plus de date plus de
représentations plus de rencontres ça
fait une vingtaine à peu près c'était il
y avait une vingtaine de compagnies à
peu près 45 spectacle qui étaient
prévues jusqu'à la fin de la saison
et puis il avait aussi des gros projets
participatifs qui impliquait 300 400
amateurs avec des gros temps de
répétition et qui implique également une
partie de l'équipe du théâtre voilà il
ya un ensemble un ensemble de choses
parce que on voit effectivement la
partie spectaculaire celle qui se voit
l'as monaco et du public
mais nous notre travail c'est 50% de
travail sur le terrain dans les
campagnes yvelinoise dans les quartiers
blinois avec des amateurs avec
différents publics
et ça c'est finalement quelque chose qui
disparaît et que l'on ne voit que très
peu disparaître
et pourtant c'est très important tel
impact
un tel arrêt sur le théâtre on sait que
les saisons vous l'avez dit se prépare
très longtemps à l'avancé il est parfois
difficile de confier de considérer les
emplois du temps de tous les artistes
on reporte sur une année sur deux
d'abord on reporte quand on peut
reporter et puis quand on peut reporter
oui sur les vins
sur les vingt compagnies en à peu près
une dizaine qui on est et qui ont pu
être reportés
soit la saison prochaine ce qui est
demandé de la souplesse également à
notre planning et aux équipes qui
étaient déjà programmé la saison
prochaine et puis la saison suivante
et puis pour les autres il était
important qu'on puisse les indemniser
parce que les annulations sont faites et
du jour au lendemain voilà ce qu'est ce
qui se passe après vous parliez des
impacts sur le sur le lieu les impacts
aujourd'hui ils sont très compliqués à
mesurer je pourrais vous dire on a perdu
tant de billetterie à partir du 13 mars
on a quinze mille billets remboursés
voilà ça je peux vous le dire mais je
peux pas vous dire quel est le manque à
gagner
et quelle sera la manque à gagner puis
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
quand on parle d' un pas qui c est ce
que les publics vont revenir et dans
quelles conditions
parce qu'on pose la liste des lieux mais
qu'en est il des publics pour que
justement en parlant de ça on parle de
mesures sanitaires à mettre en place si
jamais ça vous ouvre une mesure décriée
par jean michel ribes le directeur du
théâtre du rencontre qui dit tous les 80
spectateurs
c'est pas possible il faut voir il faut
voir là le cette mesure dans son nom
dans sa globalité
un spectateur tous les quatre ans bah
c'est un peu compliquée à imaginer mais
c'est surtout l'entrée dans le théâtre
c'est à dire que les mesures de
confinement si annecy en attend 300
personnes pour une représentation dont
une salle de 1000 places alors dû dire
ça veut dire que ce seront des files
d'attentes d'une heure une heure et
quart une heure et demie avant d'entrer
en scène une convocation des publics une
heure et demie avant après ce qui a de
très compliqué à mesurer passer un
échange que j'avais hier avec une
spectatrice
c'est qu'ils me disaient oui moi dans
tous les cas j'aurais envie de revenir
au théâtre
c'était le cas de cette spectatrice mais
globalement est ce que les spectateurs
envie de se soumettre à ces conditions
pour revenir au théâtre
peut-être qu'ils ont le courage et
l'envié des braves et on l'espère mais
la mise en oeuvre mais je suis assez
assez d'accord avec jean michel ribes ou
tout comme je suis assez d'accord avec
stéphane lissner de directeur de l'opéra
de paris qui disent que la mise en place
de ces conditions chante on être une une
purge excusez moi pardonnez moi le terme
donc ils ont aussi un certain impact a
un impact financier pas petit excusez
moi le ministère de la culture a
lancer un fonds de soutien est ce que
vous en tant que scène nationale vous
allez en bénéficier ou c'est réservé au
théâtre privé non le fonds de soutien va
être essentiellement orientée sur deux
sur les théâtres privés
nous bénéficions déjà d'un soutien de
différentes collectivités les ministères
de la culture
l'agglomération de saint quentin
financeur principal d'ailleurs du
théâtre le département la région et puis
on pourra également déclaré en chômage
partiel
donc non on n'aura pas on ne va pas
bénéficier de ce de ce fonds de soutien
d'urgence
en plus on arrive à une époque où
d'habitude vous annoncer la saison
suivante est ce que vous allez patienter
en attendant les annonces
gouvernementales est ce que vous vous
trépignez à l'annoncé comment vous vous
sentez vigne et le mot est faible
là disons que l'on retire les chevaux
pour l'instant qui sont dans le box
prête à partir prise à partie parce que
la saison lé voilà l'été boucler la
plaquette de saison elle est quasiment
prête on arrêtait l'imprimeur et été
acquitté je pense qu'il va y avoir une
communication sur la saison prochaine
par internet d'une part d une visio
présentation de saison mais pour
l'instant on est un peu dans
l'incapacité de savoir exactement ce que
l'on peut annoncer quand on peut
l'annoncer dans la mesure où on n'a
aucune nouvelle et je pense qu'on aura
rien avant la fin mai ou le tout début
du mois de juin
mais voilà on retient les chevaux pour
l'instant et puis les équipes du théâtre
ont tout de même été sur le pont en
partageant sur les réseaux sociaux leurs
coups de coeur et les conseils culturels
donc j'imagine qu'on va pouvoir encore
en avoir quelques-uns à écouter
normalement ça devrait ça devait
s'arrêter à la fin du du premier
confinement mais peut-être qu'on va
relancer la machine
si on tarde trop à dire merci à lionel
masse et âme c'est le directeur du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
merci revenus
des saisons arrêter des dates annulées
ou reportées vous l'aurez compris c'est
surtout l'incertitude qui plane pour les
salles de spectacles vivants pour le
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir et la
mairie de trappes
l'heure est à l'attenté à la réflexion
ont regardé ces annulations ne sont que
la partie émergée de l'iceberg
comme toutes les salles la merise a dû
baissé ses rideaux et mettre en suspend
tous les projets associatifs ou scolaire
tout le travail qui a été lancé avec
[Musique]
l'épée ac
et puis également tous des travaille
d'abord ça avec le public voilà donc
tout ça on a dû tout arrêter tous copé
situation identique à plaisir le théâtre
espace collége préparer résidence et
répétitions avec des compagnies pour la
directrice ce n'est que partie remise
j'en ai en septembre on a aussi des
projets d'action culturelle notamment
avec la compagnie käfig merzouki le
sociale de créteil qui avait commencé en
janvier est donc reportée grâce au
soutien du département des yvelines en
septembre mais les salles en attente de
décision gouvernementale prévue le 2
juin prochain regarde déjà vers l'avenir
nous sommes en train de rédiger un
protocole d'accueil à la fois des
professionnels qui vont venir ici mais
également du public pour les rassurer et
leur accueil dans les conditions
sanitaires au maximum au niveau sécurité
si on a possibilité d'ouvrir avec une
jauge très réduite
eh bien on fera autrement emportera les
briques taf on annulera plus rien et on
attendra d'autres suivant le la jauge
qu'on nous autorisera à voir on à vendre
à d'autres formes on accueillera des
lectures on accueillera d'autres
événements plaisir a pu repousser trois
spectacles la merise à reporter 95 % de
la programmation sur la prochaine saison
si l'incertitude est encore présent que
le monde du spectacle n'a qu'une idée en
tête
[Musique]
m
parmi les sites culturels à ré ouvrira
les châteaux le temps de mettre en place
toutes les règles sanitaires et
d'obtenir les autorisations
préfectorales les monuments peuvent à
nouveau accueillir du public c'est le
cas du château de breteuil célèbre pour
ses contes et ses illustres occupant un
geste peu attendu en ces lieux
d'histoire mais dans le château de
breteuil aussi le gel hydroalcoolique et
les masques sont primordiaux pour la
visite
les équipes ont aussi revu leur
fonctionnement nous limitons les départs
à 10 personnes et des gens évoluent
librement dans le parcours du château ce
qui est nouveau ce sont des pupitres
dans toutes les pièces pour indiquer les
donnait les explications les
commentaires de la scène et des objets
d'art que les gens peuvent voir dans
cette pièce le château a rouvert ses
grilles le 15 mai dernier les visiteurs
étaient au rendez vous la fréquentation
ressembler à celle d'un mois de juin
normal mille visiteurs ont foulé les
pelouses du domaine le dimanche 17 mai a
pris une semaine dans la vallée et on a
vu qu'ils avaient beaucoup de châteaux
où on me pose et de trois questions nous
et cela il était un joueur donc
nous voici ça fait déjà maintenant deux
mois qu'on est confiné à paris donc c
était relativement assez compliqué à
vivre
donc on a eu le début du déconfinement
balle et c'est de faire un petit
week-end elle les deux mois de fermeture
ont bien sûr eu un impact financier des
salariés sont encore en chômage partiel
les mariages ne pourrait pas reprendre
avant le 18 juillet avril mai juin sont
les gros mois pour nous puisque nous
avons entre autres toutes les sorties
scolaires de fin d'année donc depuis le
15 mars
plus aucun groupe scolaire n'est venu et
ne reviendra pas avant septembre
ces mois de fermeture vont représenter
environ le tiers du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
les équipes ont mis à profit le
confinement pour entretenir le site
après une année 2010 neuf records en
terme de fréquentation
le château de breteuil prend son mal en
patience un autre monument yvelinois ne
va pas tarder à réouvrir ses portes ou
plutôt les grid ces jardins le château
de dampierre en yvelines peaufine ses
derniers réglages sécurisation du
chantier en cours
et nouveauté une balade d'un kilomètre
et demi il dans les bosquets les
premiers visiteurs sont attendus le 30
mai d'autres sites se dévoilent depuis
le début de l'épidémie de manière un
numérique au château de versailles une
application vous propose de découvrir
jardin grands appartements et galerie
des glaces
vous pouvez aussi faire l'expérience de
réalité virtuelle suivre un mook sur
louis xiv où vous plonger dans une
exposition virtuelle elle aussi le musée
d'archéologie nationale vous donne
rendez vous sur internet le site saint
germanois vous propose des quiz des
coloriages et possède aussi son
application pour découvrir ses
collections et si la famille m résoudre
des mystères les archives
départementales vous propose d'aider
l'inspecteur archibald enquêter sur un
vol de bijoux en 1919 c'est la fin de ce
set une culture merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve prochainement pour
un nouveau numéro
[Musique]